ciao sono erika mio fratello ha cercato
di farmi diventare famosa è un
deficiente
[Musica]
la faccia
perché ho comprato una bilancio e lo
stimolo
ho provato a far diventare la famosa mia
sorella questo il titolo del mib e
questa idea appunto del titolo di far
diventare famosa mia sorella è nata
immediatamente dopo
l'epopea che ho passato su tik tok in
quel video dello show non so se vi
ricordate in quel video lì ci sono stati
un sacco di commenti che dicevano game
sei bellissimo questo video è fantastico
se la miglior persona in circolazione
sulla faccia della terra
ma questo esperimento ha valore a metà
perché tu sei un volto conosciuto tu sei
io toby e quindi farti vedere in un tic
toc li fa automaticamente andare bene e
nonostante io sia una persona molto
umile vi ringrazio calorosamente e
quindi ho deciso che avete ragione avete
ragione è l'esperimento di far diventare
qualcuno famoso da zero si deve fare con
qualcuno che non è famoso tipo mia
sorella mia sorella non è nessuno
questo è il mio ultimo video poi finirò
di notte accoltellato qui più che altro
in quel video di tik tok è arrivata
anche un sacco di gente che non mi
conosce e giusto per curiosità e non ha
preso tanto bene il fatto che io anche
il fiato che a me non sia piaciuto il 90
per cento dei contenuti all'interno
della piattaforma perché 1 l'algoritmo
dei perche cambia da persona a persona
ci sono persone che hanno solo roba [ __ ]
nei loro per tempo 2 e cito testualmente
più di un commento che ho visto scritto
sotto quel video per forza fa cagare
quello che vedi se nella parte etero di
tik tok
io
cosa vuol dire io e quindi sono separate
la parte etero e la parte lgbt di tik
tok sono due algoritmi non lo so cosa
vuol dire non ne ho idea però a quanto
pare era perché l'ha scritto più di una
persona e su internet se lo scrive più
di una persona automaticamente è vero
quindi non ne ho idea quella che poi è
diventata un idea invece è stata quella
di prendere una persona non famosa
trasformarla in famosa a tavolino quindi
tutto quello che abbiamo fatto è stato
proprio a fronte di far diventare
qualcuno un qualcuno che non è qualcuno
gambi e gli obiettivi superficiali per
mia sorella erano due farle avere un po
di pubblico sempre partendo da zero e
cercare di farle guadagnare qualcosa da
internet nel minor tempo possibile
ovviamente da solo non sarei andato da
nessuna parte quindi ho dovuto proprio
costruire un team con me mia sorella
luna che ormai conoscete abbastanza bene
e andrea il ragazzo di mia sorella tutto
perfetto ma da dove si parte
cioè io ho dovuto lavorare così per sei
mesi
[Musica]
per poter fare questa cosa e raggiungere
gli obiettivi nel minor tempo possibile
bisogna fare qualcosa di semplice
bisogna idea rsj un format più stupido
però allo stesso tempo di
intrattenimento che esista sulla faccia
della terra
sono andato a ripescare direttamente
nella youtube del 2011
iamm box il perché non serve una grande
messa in scena per girarli perché sono
facili da montare
ed è facile reperire il materiale ma non
è che puoi aprire facchi e basta nei tic
toc devi dare un motivo alla gente per
guardarli tutti devi avere una piccola
idea e un micro format dietro e l'idea è
stata quella di non dire america cosa ci
fosse all'interno dei parchi quindi ogni
scatola per lei è una sorpresa e un'idea
rimbambita si è un'idea funzionale con
quello che dobbiamo fare è probabile
luna sarebbe stata in carico del
montaggio dei video in modo da non farli
montare a me dopo 15 anni ma mi metto
pure a montare i video di altre persone
pure se un progetto mio con ritmi
serrati e tagli molto veloci per evitare
di appesantirsi tutto il lavoro abbiamo
deciso anche di fare un ambientazione
super semplice pulita un muro
monocromatico un tavolo pure lui
monocromatico una sedia è una luce
dietro nome del progetto erika
rompiscatole vero
per due o tre motivi
cretina e tutto questo brainstorming c'è
stato ad ottobre 2000 21 gli ha dato
alla testa
la fame
[Risate]
facciamo una primissima prova di
montaggio colore inquadratura e a quanto
pare funziona
cosa dico che non ha un'apertura
il problema del formato verticale e che
quando vuoi far vedere una tavolata
piena di oggetti con le scatole che si
aprono le cose che vengono fuori devi
stare attento a non farla troppo stretta
non farla troppo larga altrimenti il
soggetto diventa piccolino al centro la
mia paura era che la pulizia visiva
nonostante il contenuto semplice la
pulizia visiva e un certo controllo dei
colori potessero far sembrare i tic toc
dell'espulso digitate in una media
casereccia dei tic toc normali quando
tuscany scorri 45 e poi che appare sotto
il pollice una sponsorizzata tipo di
un'azienda tipo calvin klein la noti la
differenza c'è si vede che è fatto con
una telecamera diverse con una pulizia
diversa e mi era venuta questa immensa
paura che la gente potesse scambiarli
per uno di quelli heskey parli male
abbiamo fatto anche qualche foto concept
per capire un po il mood di tutto
l'insieme qualche foto singola qualche
foto di gruppo qualche foto scema
qualche foto seria qualche foto che
sarebbe potuto diventare in futuro anche
l'avatar del canale eccetera eccetera ma
soprattutto si inizia a pensare a cosa
mettere dentro quelle benedette scatole
da farle aprire oggetti strani
giocattoli particolari e unici cibo
buffo la bici degli han boxing del 2011
e in un attimo arriviamo a novembre 2000
venture
finalmente iniziano le vere riprese è
sempre per evitare di appesantire tutti
gli altri progetti di tutte e quattro le
persone decidiamo di girare il numero
più alto di vibio nel minor tempo
possibile
bravo sì ma che così mi fai tu da
backstage e
bastano una decina di minuti di girato
per ogni singolo unboxing per riuscire a
tirare fuori qualcosa la cosa più
difficile ora è cercare di rendere
naturale mia sorella una telecamera
perché io lo so che mia sorella è molto
spigliata e molto ironiche molto
simpatica e ci sa fare però quando sei
davanti alla telecamera c'è una serie di
problemi e di blocchi psicologici che
non vi sto a dire io sono nella dieta di
no e
infatti i primi video sono stati più di
riscaldamento che altro e mi è salita a
questa sensazione bellissima
nel gestire un progetto mio in cui io
non sono il protagonista è una cosa che
mi ha fatto pensare parecchio questa ed
infatti eravamo presi talmente tanto
bene che lo sfondata quella poveraccia
di mia sorella gli abbiamo fatto fare
quattro cambi di felpa quattro cambi di
set e in una giornata sola e abbiamo
girato mi sembra 15 16 video allora
all'inizio è stato un po un trauma nel
senso che il giorno prima ero innanzi a
piena un po di ansia da prestazione
perché più difficile
di quello che può sembrare devi parlare
da sola con una videocamera dove non c'è
nessuno che ti risponde la seconda
mandata di ripresa è stata fatta a
dicembre 2000 21 al mese dopo
qual è lo sponsor dei miei video
nord bienne ha quindi devo fare tipolo
sponsored by pn scaricate largo bn col
codice io toby basta ne parliamo dopo ne
parliamo dopo una cosa che è saltata
fuori durante la giornata di dicembre è
stata che più interazioni ci sono tra
erica e noi dietro la telecamera più
divertente il video quando erika magari
fa qualcosa di scemo ridiamo delle sue
disgrazie
e solo quelle piccole aggiunte che
rendono uno più naturale il video a chi
lo sta guardando due più divertente e
tra l'altro in quel periodo lì dove
andavamo andavamo ogni singolo oggetto
diventava questo lo possono far aprire
erika anche in questo ci divertiamo un
sacco a guardarsi primi svuota le tasche
vede un attimo cosa ci hai qualche vite
facciamole aprire le cose nel e vespa
stacca una trave dal soffitto mettiamola
dentro una scatola e tutto questo ai non
ha fatto altro che dare per noi nella
nostra testa più valore all'intero
progetto di unboxing di oggetti di merda
alla fine era guarito
[Musica]
aver fatto le foto in precedenza ci
aiuta ad avere già un avatar decente una
foto recente da caricare che riassuma un
pochino erika rompiscatole lotto di
gennaio parte ufficialmente il canale
con il primo video il barattolo
portamonete dovrebbe essere un
salvadanaio che conta tutti i soldi che
hai dentro la decisione iniziale quella
di caricare un video al giorno per
almeno un mese senza sponsorizzarlo da
nessuna parte per evitare di intaccare
l'algoritmo niente ai 50 euro in moneta
tutto quello che c'è mia dopo la prima
settimana la situazione decisamente
buona alcuni video sono finiti nei per
te e ci sono rimasti per qualche ora il
set per traforo fa quasi 5000 visuali in
un paio di giorni e anche due dopo non
sono andati troppo lontani ma nella
seconda settimana la svolta i precedenti
vide iniziano piano piano ad ingranare
fermandosi intorno alle 3 mila visual ma
è con la rim light per i self che arriva
il primo
lancio vero 23 k in meno di 24 ore sono
passati al massimo una decina di giorni
e il progetto sta già funzionando
però tu hai una porta di ingresso
nell'ufficio e non voi che la sindrome
dell'impostore ti venga a bussare
infatti mi faccio venire i dubbi su
quanto effettivamente stia funzionando
il canale perché io conosco l'andamento
e i numeri dei canali famosi di tik tok
ma non ho idea di quelli nuovi e facendo
una piccola ricerca scopro che i nostri
numeri sono molto più alti di quello che
pensassi io ero convinto che l'algoritmo
di tik tok che assicurasse un minimo
sindacabile di visualizzazioni ad ogni
tic toc caricato un qualcosa tra le 500
e le mille in modo da far macinare
l'algoritmo per far capire sento video
piacciono le persone ma non è
assolutamente così anzi c'è un sacco di
gente che prima di arrivare alle 500
visual passa decine e decine di
caricamenti con 10 5 15 viso al massimo
quindi riguardando i numeri anche i
primi video con 400 visual non sono
andati così male a sto punto mi chiedo
come andrà febbraio
farò io che do dovuto montare tutti i
video è stato difficile perché ormai io
vivevo e pensavo con la sua voce
è una bellissima voce
certo
il video della self e rim light arriva a
100.000 visualizzazioni e questo spinge
l'algoritmo di tik tok a far elaborare a
far entrare dei per te anche successivi
video la tazza per pigri caricata subito
dopo la rim light fa 114mila e da lì
togliendo il panettone delle winx che fa
solo 15.000 si stabilizza il canale ed
inizia a crescere regolare con ogni
caricamento in meno di 24 ore ogni
singolo video caricato fa almeno 30mila
visual due anni che il papa era che
erano potere una pistola in mano e tutto
questo in meno di un mese cioè questi
sono i numeri di un canale di youtube
che cresce abbiamo trasformato tik tok e
youtube questo è perché siamo tarati
manager abbiamo sbagliato tutto abbiamo
abbiamo cambiato l'algoritmo in modo che
fosse stabile ma non è così che funziona
la mia voce dove dov'è finita la mia
voce è come se avessimo fidelizzato un
pubblico che però non è che ci segue
perché soltanto dopo un mese abbiamo
toccato i 10 mila follower e allora
andiamo a vedere i commenti vediamo cosa
dice la gente
e i commenti sono pochi e va abbastanza
superfluo e tutto sta andando
oltre le mie più rosee aspettative
ora dobbiamo soltanto andare avanti e
non fare cazzate
tu pensa un po
mia sorella più di 18 anni abbiamo più
di 10 mila follower e negli ultimi 30
giorni abbiamo fatto più di 100.000
misura sapete cosa vuol dire che
possiamo attivare la monetizzazione e ci
stiamo avvicinando al secondo obiettivo
di questo progetto far guadagnare mia
sorella con internet e decidiamo di
attivare la monetizzazione con un
caricamento molto specifico un enorme
costume per emoji sotto carnevale
come se l'idea hanno bussato sapete che
è alla porta è un enorme cazzo nel culo
che rovinerà a questo progetto
il video guarda caso per forma molto
sotto la norma rispetto tutti gli ultimi
tutti loro hanno fatto quasi 50 mila in
meno di 24 ore
lui guarda caso è in due giorni ne fa al
pelo 20 ma sarà un caso carichiamolo un
altro che fa 7 mila carichiamo non altro
che fa 2000 che sta succedendo
io andrea abbiamo fatto un video con
karim sul canale di karima appunto dove
andrea era detective e io ero quella
tutte incappucciata che sembrava un
sacco preso così dalla spazzatura bianca
ero io solo che non mi vedeva nessuno
perché ero tutta imbacuccata e quindi
fermano andrea non fermano ma è vero
succede che ho involontariamente
confermato un piccolo sospetto che la
gente a da tanto tempo quando inizia a
guadagnare che tocchi in qualche modo ti
tarpa le ali purtroppo sono soltanto
congetture sono soltanto speculazione ma
ho letto
tantissime testimonianze di persone a
cui è successa la stessa identica cosa
un calo di visual immediatamente dopo
l'attivazione della monetizzazione del
creators fund molta gente si è rivolta
tik tok chiedendo spiegazioni
dell'avvenimento e tic toc ha risposto a
questa accusa è dicendo sempre la stessa
cosa dovete stare al passo con i tempi
gli hashtag cambiano i trend girano
quello che famoso il giorno prima non è
più famoso il giorno dopo che sono tutte
cose verissimo che però non si applica a
noi che abbiamo creato un canale
completamente staccato da tendenze
hashtag del momento al terzo video
affossato decidiamo di toglierci
immediatamente dal creators found e
subito si nota una variazione importante
da 4.000 a 17.000 visual ma il canale ha
decisamente subito una batosta enorme
perché da lì fino alla fine del progetto
i numeri sono
completamente a caso prima avevamo un
quadro specifico dopo è andato tutto in
mano alla casualità alcune addirittura
dicono che per loro non c'è stata
nessuna variazione o addirittura sono
aumentati i numeri non avere i mezzi per
comprendere esattamente cosa stia
succedendo mi manda ai pazzi questa cosa
tra l'altro ha avuto anche un
piccolissimo per l'amor di dio impatto
psicologico su tutto il gruppo perché
abbiamo proprio visto funzionare una
cosa che abbiamo preparato per mesi per
poi farci togliere il pallone da sotto i
piedi e volete sapere qual è la cosa
peggiore di tutta questa storia è che i
tre video monetizzati che in tutto hanno
fatto circa 35.000 visual hanno fatto
guadagnare al canale zero euro
letteralmente zero euro non è apparso
niente nessuna statistica nessuno in
file e mo pure lì vai a capire che è
successo abbiamo aspettato purtroppo
poco siamo usciti dalla monetizzazione
troppo in fretta chi cazzo lo saprà mai
ma ad un certo punto tramite il
programma di affiliazione del creator
found dal nulla completamente veniamo
contattati per una proposta lavorativa
ci contatta un'azienda cinese per farci
sponsorizzare
una bilancia non da cucina una bilancia
da persone e noi accettiamo in voglio
dire perché non un singolo video del
prodotto in cambio di una cifra di
denaro scelta da noi inizia ad arrivarci
tutti i flash mentali di cosa potrebbe
succedere dopo il primo ad del del
canale con 15.000 20.000 di sbocco una
settimana la risposta è stata il vostro
canale non è compatibile con il nostro
prodotto ma scusate ma
chi ha soldi
perché è tutto non lo so cosa è successo
dal caricamento in poi soprattutto
perché un mese dopo si ripresentano
contattando direttamente mia sorella su
whatsapp le dicono non vi preoccupate
rimandate la richiesta ma mortacci mia
sorella rimanda la richiesta arriva da
tutto e nulla non si fanno sentire il
mio sorella rimanda la richiesta e non
si fanno più sentire una donna è qui in
questo delirio si conclude il progetto
erika non pescato io non so neanche come
raccapezzare tutto il discorso è
successo un casino dietro l'altro di
successi di fallimenti e dvd dubbi di
domande mai risposte di cinesi di
bilancio ma è un casino quali è successo
in tre mesi il delirio e tra l'altro
tutti quanti video hanno recuperato le
viso anche quelli che durante la
monetizzazione sono andati malissimo
sono tutti 30 40mila ce n'è uno che ha
fatto i soldi finti affatto 140.000
quindi qualcosa più o meno in virale ci
va ancora e dei due obiettivi uno quello
di farle avere dei follower partendo da
zero e farla diventare tra virgolette
famosa ce l'abbiamo fatta siamo riusciti
a farlo l'altro mancava così poco in
quattro mesi siamo riusciti a fare così
tanto e tra la monetizzazione e la
sponsorizzazione mancava così poco per
farla guadagnare non ce l'ho fatta porta
bene
piedi
[Musica]
non ci stupiscono
siete delle merde il giro di do
ma cosa devo dire al nord i pm per nord
pn puoi creare un vero oltre al papà tu
che adesso sei in iraq con nordi p n
puoi collegarti un italiano e vedere
contenuti di netflix che ci sono in
italia fu cordari bastardi di
pizzofalcone rappresenti e se ti
connetti a delle reti pubbliche per
esempio cosa fanno il vpn protegge tutti
i tuoi dati in bravissimo è quindi per
il codice gli hot ob avrete uno stronzo
esclusivo